really excited to show you what we've
got i think it's going to
blow your mind all of your senses your
sight hearing feeling um
pain these are all electrical signals
sent by neurons to your brain but these
can all be solved with an implantable
neural link this is sort of what it
looks like
this is that little device it does that
thing at the bottom is just to hold the
threads in place because they're just
like little fine
wires in a lot of ways it's kind of like
a fitbit in your skull with tiny wires
all you can see afterwards is there's a
tiny scar and if it's under your hair
you can't see it at all in fact i could
have a neural link right now and you
wouldn't know maybe i do
so and it's also got all the things that
you would expect to see
the sensors you'd expect to see in a
smart watch uh
or a phone uh so there's actually a lot
of functions that this device could do
uh related to monitoring your health and
warning you about a possible heart
attack or stroke or other
damage as well as sort of convenience
features like playing music
um you could do a lot it's sort of like
if your
phone went at your brain or something um
yeah maybe that's not a great analogy
um all right so it's also inductively
charged so
um it's charged in the same way that you
showed you charge a smartwatch or a
phone
um and so you can use it all day uh
charge it at night
and have full functionality so in terms
of getting a link essentially
uh you remove uh about a coin sized
piece of skull
then the robot inserts the electrodes
then the device replaces the portion of
skull that was removed
and we we basically closed that up with
actually a super glue which is how a lot
of wounds are closed
so this is our surgical robot and we
actually ultimately want this robot to
do
essentially the entire surgery so in
everything from from incision uh
removing the the skull inserting the
electrodes placing the device
um and then um closing things up so
does it actually work uh what i'm
excited to show you
um i'll quote like the the three little
pigs demo well i'll walk right over
and show you
so what we have in pen number one is
joyce and she does not have an implant
obviously healthy and happy so here's
dorothy
and in the case of dorothy dorothy used
to have an implant
and then we removed the implant so this
is
a very important thing to demonstrate is
reversibility
so if you if you have a neural link and
then you decide you don't want it or you
want to get an upgrade
and the neural link is removed um is it
removed in such a way that you are still
healthy and happy afterwards
man gertrude are you serious
[Laughter]
okay
um oh the beauty of live demos this was
real live demo
all right here we go great okay
great this is a
high energy pig um all right
gertrude thanks for coming out um
so what you're the beeps you're hearing
are real-time
signals from the neural link in gotri's
head
so this neural link connects to neurons
that are
uh in her snout so whenever she snuffles
around
and touches something with a snout but
that sends out
uh neural spikes which are detected here
she's had the implant for two months so
this is a
healthy and happy pig with an implant
that is two months old two months old
and working well
and we're able to show that you can
actually have multiple neural links
implanted
um and again healthy and happy and
indistinguishable from a normal pig
and in terms of additional brain reading
activity
when we have um say one of our pigs on a
treadmill
and put it on a treadmill it's very
funny concept really
and we take the readings from the
neurons
we're able with a wireless neural neural
implant to actually predict the position
of of all of the limbs uh in the pig's
body now in terms of
of writing to the brain or stimulating
neurons so you can see them lighting up
different brain regions
and then by carefully controlling the
electric field you can actually
have one electrode influence
possibly a thousand or ten thousand
neurons and we're making good progress
towards clinical studies
i'm excited to announce that we received
a breakthrough device designation from
the fda in july
thanks to the hard work of the knurling
team
we'll make this as safe as possible
just as with tesla while it is legally
possible to ship a one star car
at tesla we the only cars we make are
five stars
in in every category so we actually
maximize safety and we'll take the same
approach
here at neural link so we'll do live q a
uh so
bring in a bunch of people from the
neuralink team will you be able to save
and replay memories in the future
uh yes i think uh in the future you will
be able to save and
replay memories um i mean this is
obviously sounding increasingly like a
black mirror episode um
but uh well i guess they're pretty good
predicting
over time we could actually give
somebody supervision uh like you could
have like
ultra violet or infrared or see in radar
and actually have a superhuman vision
can the neurolink chip
allow you to summon your tesla
telepathically
definitely of course you heard it here
first that's a definite 100 percent
carlos that is the answer with with this
implant you can actually
think just just by thinking you can
output
words and you can you can type and you
can control a computer
control a phone and uh which is
pretty pretty wild any estimate of how
much it will cost at launch
and what price it will reduce to over
time
i i think at launch it's probably going
to be it
i would say that's not really
representative because at first
i think it's going to be you know quite
expensive but that price will very
rapidly drop
and i think over time we want to get the
the cost
um obviously down as low as possible but
i think
um inclusive of the automated surgery i
think we want to get the
the price down to a few thousand dollars
thank you very much
thanks so much for watching i'm cindy
palm if you like what you saw give it a
like and don't forget to subscribe to my
new channel
also i'm always looking for good stories
to tell so if you have a store idea
feel free to leave it in the comment
section below see you soon
[Music]
you